[Musique]
là on les détache tout simplement sans
les se détacher tout seul voilà voilà
voilà l'aiguillette oui on l'a mais là
on sort l'autre ça se détacher parce que
vraiment c'est tellement tendre on est
bon c'est tout ce que vous reprenez dans
ces quarts 15 lorsque vous utilisez
autre chose voilà alors tout ce qui
reste de la viande on racle oui et puis
alors on se sert aussi de l'eau clics et
quelques éclairs de l'éducation les
claies que c'est ça c est ce que c'est
ça c'est quand on reconnaît un mâle
d'une femelle est quand même à éclipser
les cow boys du canard bon je veux pas
vous dire autre chose partie essentielle
du mas exactement et regarder cela comme
personnel alors là on va s'en servir
saint cyr toujours a non seulement servi
voilà on aimait la à macérer dans
l'armagnac et le sauternes ce n'est pas
à cracher dessus